this is the Unseen face of Ukraine's
counter-offensive
the men and women who are sacrificing
their lives for every inch of land
but with it comes the risk this Soldier
stepped on a landmine
Medics don't have a lot of time to
stabilize him
his colleagues on the battlefield
managed to stop the bleeding but he
still needs attention before he can be
taken to a proper Hospital even as these
Medics work to save lives their own
lives are constantly under threat
they're as close as they can possibly be
to the front line with the battle going
on all around them
in the Next Room another patient is
brought in with shrapnel wounds to his
face the sound of constant firing and
shelling can be heard the vibration of
the strikes felt throughout this
Hospital
we're not allowed to reveal the location
except that it's close to the eastern
city of bakmut Russian forces took
control of it in May the Ukrainian
military is trying to get it back the
soldier is now stable he's lost his foot
but is alive during moments of
short-lived quiet Medics rest and rate
for the next set of casualties
due to the good training of our Medics
many of those injured survive one of the
issues is the enemy uses anti-personal
Minds it will take a long time after the
victory at least 10 years for us to
clear those Minds
a lot of the equipment and supplies is
donated many Medics are also volunteers
the most difficult thing is that we're
very short on time here if they are in a
critical State seconds matter it
determines whether they live or die the
most shocking thing is that when you
have Soldiers with no arms or legs they
ask when will I be able to fight again
for everyone involved it's a risky task
the road in and out is on a dirt track
through winding Fields all other routes
are within sight of Russian forces and
easily hit even those leaving the field
Hospital have to be transported quickly
so they don't come under Fire
the hospital only moves location if the
front lines move further away but with
intense fighting taking place and no
real change these Medics expect a steady
flow of casualties as I beg Al Jazeera
near bakmud front line eastern Ukraine